what's up with everyone's favorite
die-hard star bruce willis and his
movies lately did you notice his small
cameo in the lego movie 2 the second
part why isn't he really starring in
anything big lately keep watching to
find out
for decades bruce willis wasn't just a
big name actor he was one of the more
reliable box office draws out there just
look at his stretch of film credits from
1994 to 2000 when he managed to star in
six separate films five of them
completely original projects that all
grossed north of 200 million dollars
worldwide the fact that these
productions varied greatly in genre from
science fiction to thriller to action
blockbuster was a testament to the
appeal that willis had audiences were
willing to follow him nearly everywhere
especially when he was reprising his die
hard role of john mclean his financial
credibility continued into the 21st
century when he began to play on
people's nostalgia for his 1980s works
this fueled the box office success of
productions like live free or die hard
even into the 2010s willis was still
headlining lucrative projects like
looper and red giving him further hits
roughly 25 years after his first leading
man role in the movie blind date all in
all the combined worldwide box office
grosses of willis's films has tallied
well over 6.7 billion dollars this sum
puts him ahead of other famous lead
actors such as liam neeson hugh jackman
and jennifer lawrence among many others
if one were going by his box office
prowess for decades it would seem
inconceivable that willis would ever be
caught in the mire of direct to video
cinema
even still not every movie willis has
appeared in has become a box office hit
even the man responsible for launching
the die hard movies is capable of
appearing in notorious duds like north
in 2013 willis experienced two
especially notable disappointments in
the form of red two and a good day to
die hard the latter title wasn't exactly
a wipeout since it made 304.2 million
dollars worldwide on a 92 million dollar
budget however it hit a new box office
low for the die hard saga in north
america and also made less than its two
direct predecessors at the international
box office red 2 meanwhile made
considerably less than its predecessor
and failed to crack 150 million dollars
globally
don't look at me she's your girlfriend
with these discouraging financial
developments a new franchise was stopped
dead in its tracks the comparative
failure of these two 2013 titles was
especially distressing since unlike past
willis box office duds like surrogates
both of these tentpoles were part of
supposedly bulletproof franchises if
willis could no longer be relied on to
draw in moviegoers within the confines
of sequels that was a major problem the
fact that these two projects were
following up other than recent willis
box office non-starters like cop out
only rubbed further salt in these wounds
while not the sole reason he embraced
dtv releases the box office woes willis
experienced in 2013 reflected his
diminishing returns as a big screen draw
it was inevitable then that he'd look
for alternative places to continue his
leading man career
just happened
as late as the 2010s willis was also
still showing up in theatrical releases
like the cold light of day that didn't
carry massive costs and weren't based on
pre-existing properties even red though
technically a dc comics adaptation was
made in these confines thanks to its 58
million budget however his opportunities
to appear in such projects began to
dwindle as the 2010s went on and major
theatrical movie studios began to shift
away from mid-budget projects studios
like warner brothers were now interested
in launching long-term cinematic
universes not the sort of one-off hits
that willis had consistently spun into
gold in years past with fewer and fewer
opportunities to show up in titles of
the scale of 16 blocks in theaters it's
easy to imagine that the age of direct
to video cinema would suddenly look a
lot more appealing to willis yet in 2015
bruce willis secured a very impressive
acting gig a supporting role in the
woody allen movie cafe society pairing
up this performer with jesse eisenberg
and kristen stewart willis was set to
play eisenberg's boss who becomes
embroiled in a love triangle that
involves stewart's character willis it
appeared had secured another
high-profile art house gig unfortunately
a few days into principal photography
the cafe society production made the
sudden announcement that willis would no
longer be a part of the feature rumors
swirled that willis had been let go
after having difficulty memorizing his
lines a problem that produced a strain
for the other actors leaving cafe
society and his then recent spat with
sylvester stallone which led to his
character getting written out of the
expendables 3 speak to his difficulty in
the 2010s on maintaining consistent
mainstream work direct-to-video movies
weren't just an easy paycheck they were
also a fallback now that willis was
struggling to secure steady theatrical
movie gigs tell me about it when
moviegoers sat down in theaters to see
sin city a dame to kill for few could
have imagined that this was one of the
last theatrical releases willis would
appear in for years except for a brief
appearance in the 2015 barry levinson
feature rock the casbah and a cameo in
the 2017 m night shyamalan thriller
split willis would spend the next four
years exclusively embracing direct to
video cinema instead 2015 titles like
vice and extraction set the mold for the
kind of features that willis would begin
cranking out constantly in the years to
come many of these movies were action or
thriller flicks ones that featured
willis in a prominent capacity on their
posters that didn't reflect his screen
time 2016 would further cement his
commitment to this type of cinema while
a movie from that year precious cargo
took the actor to new lows in terms of
general critical reception while critics
were jeering willis only got more
involved with these direct-to-video
projects as the years went by it's too
strange a 2021 vulture piece on producer
randall emmett provided some clarity on
why bruce willis kept appearing in these
direct-to-video movies specifically it's
mentioned that many of the features
willis appeared in involved roles that
the actor spent only a handful of days
or even a single afternoon filming the
quick turnaround time in theory provided
a win-win scenario for all willis could
get the work done quickly while the
producers could have a big name to put
on the movie's poster this method of
filming also allowed willis to do many
direct-to-video titles in a single year
after all when it takes just a handful
of days to take care of these
performances it becomes a lot easier to
cram multiple turns in one year compare
that to the lengthy shooting schedules
of willis's earlier films which often
limited how many features willis could
headline in a single year on unbreakable
for example m night shyamalan would
engage in meticulous and time-consuming
efforts to get each shot perfectly right
the lengthy time spent on principal
photography on such features is like
something from a different planet
compared to the shooting schedules of
willis's direct to video titles
bruce willis seldom does press or
interviews for his direct-to-video
movies therefore it's difficult to ask
him questions regarding what drew him to
projects like midnight and the switch
grass however a movie john interview
with cosmic sin director edward blake
does lend some potential insight into
why willis has become enamored with
direct-to-video cinema in this interview
blake reflects on the circumstances that
led to willis appearing in cosmic sin as
it turns out the duo had worked together
before blake had previously gotten a
call to write an earlier movie called
anti-life later renamed breach the
project's entire existence was
predicated solely on willis wanting to
do a sci-fi movie while willis has been
able to exert creative control in his
theatrical movie endeavors it's doubtful
he could just will a sci-fi movie into
existence in a matter of days like this
plus this actor has often been rumored
or alleged to want greater creative
control on the projects he headlines
including productions ranging from
moonlighting to cop-out within the
confines of direct-to-video movies
willis can finally get his wish and
exert considerably more influence as a
creative participant you having fun yet
i'll let you know when i started having
fun part of why you've seen so many
direct-to-video bruce willis movies
lately isn't just because the actor is
desperate for money or loves the scripts
he's handed many of these projects exist
solely because of contractual
obligations in recent years willis has
signed multiple contracts with
production companies to appear in a
certain number of movies in a short
period one of the earliest major
instances of this came about in 2018
when willis agreed to show up in
multiple emmett furla movies a little
over two years later willis would re-up
his contract with this production outfit
for further feature-length endeavors
ensuring that willis wasn't moving away
from direct-to-video territory anytime
soon this means there's a mandatory
nature to willis's appearances in these
features it's not inconceivable that his
commitments to these multi-movie
contracts are enough to keep him tied up
even when theatrical movie releases
offer him a potential role with these
deals in play the long-term nature of
willis's commitment to direct-to-video
action films becomes a lot clearer
though direct-to-video movies have
dominated bruce willis's post 2013
career he still managed to appear in a
handful of theatrical movies in 2018
willis returned to starring in big
screen action fair with the eli roth
directed remake of death wish the film's
marketing leaned into the idea of this
being willis's first theatrical star
vehicle in a while by staging this
project as a comeback for willis death
wish posters even flouted the tagline
bruce is back unfortunately the eventual
48.5 million dollar worldwide gross of
death wish was far from a rousing return
to the glory days of willis's box office
prowess meanwhile in 2019 willis
appeared in a trio of theatrical
releases each varying greatly in terms
of screen time he was one of the lead
characters of glass a sequel to his 2000
film unbreakable that thriller grossed
246.9 million dollars worldwide making
it the 12th biggest title willis has
ever appeared in globally a welcome
departure from his box office blues in
the 2010s willis also appeared in a
cameo as himself in the lego movie 2 the
second part and also had a supporting
role in edward norton's directorial
effort motherless brooklyn the latter of
which sank at the box office not all of
these films were as big of money makers
as armageddon but the very presence of
willis in four theatrical films across
2018 and 2019 suggested that he hadn't
entirely abandoned big screen
entertainment
as early as 2017 sites like den of geek
were fascinated by how often willis was
going to the well of direct to video for
easy paychecks a few years and countless
movies later this career downturn has
become downright notorious everyone from
the new york times to pop culture writer
nathan rabin has penned pieces exploring
the shortcomings of these movies this is
often come with ruminations on why a man
who used to headline gargantuan
theatrical hits is diving headfirst into
these films even with his retirement
from acting after being diagnosed with
aphasia he's still got plenty of
upcoming titles perfectly made for
redbox kiosks the imdb page for bruce
willis is littered with forthcoming
features that will be sent directly to
the small screen upcoming adventures
include a pairing with michael rooker
called corrective measures which will be
one of the first original movies
released on toby also pulp fiction fans
can prepare for willis and john travolta
to reunite in paradise city his lengthy
list of upcoming direct-to-video star
vehicles even includes a second sequel
to the 2021 feature fortress the reasons
leading to willis's current career
status are multi-faceted and complicated
and while fans might infer that his
health issues are a factor in his recent
roles willis himself has remained silent
on the matter regardless his direct to
video movies will remain part of his
legacy alongside his blockbuster turns
check out one of our newest videos right
here plus even more looper videos about
your favorite actors are coming soon
subscribe to our youtube channel and hit
the bell so you don't miss a single one
[Music]